The notion of orthogonality
is extremely powerful.
Fundamentally, it gives us a tool for
decomposing objects into combinations
of simpler objects in a structured way.
Let's explore one of the first phenomena
that are consequences of orthogonality.
For this video,
let b be a constant vector.
Or you can think of the b as
standing for the word basis.
It will be useful to think of b as
emanating from the origin and then to
imagine a line l through the origin
that contains the arrow representing b.
We're going to consider the process
of projecting a vector v
onto the basis vector b.
One way to describe what this means is
to let v emanate from the origin and
then imagine rotating your point of
view until you are looking at b and
v in the same plane.
Then measure the apparent magnitude of
the arrow v from this point of view.
Unless v and b are perfectly parallel,
v will look shorter than it actually is.
The shorter arrow is
the projection of v onto b
which we will denote by proj sub b of v.
Or v with two little bars next to it for
short.
Another way to describe projection
is to draw a right triangle
whose hypotenuse is
the arrow depicting v.
And one of whose legs
lies on the line l.
If we draw a vector from
the origin along this leg,
that drawn vector will also be
the projection of v onto b.
The remaining leg is
perpendicular to the line l,
and therefore orthogonal to b.
If we draw a vector along this leg,
the drawn vector is the component of
the orthogonal to b which we can denote
v with a an upside down t called v perp.
Remember a definition of
the sum of two vectors?
Since we have formed a chain of two
arrows from the tail to the head of v,
we can say that the sum of
these two vectors is v.
In other words,
v equals the parallel plus the perp.
We have written v as a sum of two
vectors, one that is parallel to b and
the other that is orthogonal to b.
This is something that
occurs often in mathematics.
Given a nonzero basis vector
we can express any vector
as a sum of two vectors, one that's
parallel to the basis vector and
one that is orthogonal
to the basis vectors.
All right, so
is there a nice way to compute the
projection of v onto the basis vector b?
Let's start by making
a simplifying assumption.
Let's assume that the angle between
v and b is at most 90 degrees.
If you remember soh-CAH-toa from
trigonometry remember that the CAH means
that the cos sign of the angle of
a right triangle is equal to the ratio
of the adjacent edge to the angle and
the hypotenuse.
In other words, the cosine of
theater is equal to the length of
v parallel divided by the length of v.
After some rearranging, that means
that the length of the v parallel
is the length of v times
the cosine of theta.
Now we're going to use our dot
product formula from earlier.
Substituting this expression in for
cosine theta we get that the length
of v parallel equals the length
of v times this expression.
Since we have a factor of the length
of v in the numerator and
denominator of the expression,
we can cancel them.
And then we can rewrite what's left
over as v.u sub b whereas u sub b
is the unit vector in the direction
of b i.e., the normalization.
All right, so
I cleaned up some of these formulas and
just left what we need going
forward the length of v parallel
is equal to the dot product of just
v with the normalization of b.
Now because we made this simplifying
assumption that theta is less than or
equal to 90 degrees we know that v
parallel will point in
the same direction as b.
We also know that the normalization
of b is a unit vector.
So it will have magnitude one.
What these two facts tell us is that
if we scale the normalization of b by
exactly the length of v parallel there
will actually get the vector v parallel.
imagine taking a unit vector that's
right here and just stretching it
just the amount needed to get to v
parallel that's what we're doing.
Now let's plug in this expression for
the length of the parallel.
And what we end up with is this formula.
V parallel is exactly
the normalization of b
times the scalar v dot
the normalization of b.
Now what if we didn't make
the simplifying assumption?
What if theta were
greater than 90 degrees?
That negative sign from earlier will
carry through all the way to this
expression here.
We'll also have to make a change here
because v parallel will now point
in the opposite direction of b.
Since v parallel is pointing in the
opposite direction this formula will now
become a negative but
now when we plug this expression in for
a length of v parallel then
the negative signs will cancel out and
we'll get the same formula.
So regardless of the assumptions that
we make on this angle will always get
the same formula for v parallel in other
words the projection of v on to b.